Salut, après un an et demi de vidéos,
de spectacles et d'écriture de livre :
j'ai décidé de faire une pause cet été.
Pour me reposer, oui, mais aussi pour vous préparer
une renaissance de la chaîne en septembre.
Je vous ai demandé sur Twitter si vous vouliez
quelques facts rapides et divertissants
en attendant.
Alors pendant ces 60 jours de pause
je vous laisse une vidéo rapide et sans prétention
tous les jours pairs à 11 heures.
On se retrouve à la rentrée et...
tout de suite !
Si vous voulez gagner un million de dollars
il vous suffit de résoudre la petite énigme suivante :
Tout nombre entier pair supérieur à 3
peut s'écrire comme la somme
de deux nombres premiers.
Où est l'énigme dans cette phrase ?
Pas directement dans la phrase,
en fait il suffit juste de le prouver.
De donner une preuve de ça.
Et vous gagnerez un million de dollars.
C'est Tony Faber, un éditeur de livres,
qui a lancé ce défi-là
d'offrir un million de dollars à qui
arriverait à donner une preuve,
mathématiques donc,
de cette phrase-là.
Et aujourd'hui :
personne n'a réussi.
L'énigme n'est pas vraiment une énigme,
ça s'appelle une conjecture
et c'est la Conjecture de Goldbach
C'est l'un des plus anciens problèmes
mathématiques non résolus.
Il y a beaucoup de problèmes mathématiques
non résolus encore ce jour
avec de gens qui dédient leur vie entière à ça.
Mais celle de Goldbach est sûrement la plus ancienne.
La version que je viens de vous en donner
c'est-à-dire "tout nombre entier pair supérieur à 3
peut s'écrire comme la somme
de deux nombres premiers"
est une reformulation simplifiée
qui a été faite en 1749.
Et un nombre premier, qu'est-ce-que c'est ?
[Imitant Sarkozy]
Bah écoutez, moi je vais vous le dire.
C'est un nombre qui ne peut se diviser que par 1, évidemment, ou par lui-même.
Comme 1, 2, 3, 5, 7, 11, 13, 17, etc.
Y a rien qui fait ça × ça = 13
Ça n'existe pas.
Et donc, effectivement, si on prend
un entier pair supérieur à 3,
par exemple directement 4 :
On peut l'écrire 2+2.
Qui sont des nombres premiers.
6, on peut l'écrire 3+3.
8, on peut l'écrire 3+5.
Etc, etc.
A chaque fois, c'est possible.
Si cet été, vous voulez gagner un million de dollars,
vous pouvez vous atteler à ça.
Comme d'habitude vous pouvez liker
ou vous abonner.
Rt moi je vous donne rendez-vous dans deux jours,
puisque c'est le principe,
une vidéo tous les deux jours,
jusqu'au 30 août.
A après-demain.  Ciao !
[Musique générique de fin]